if you answered a sync task then you're
correct
to understand why we chose async task
it's the answer we can check the
developer documentation in this API
guide on processes and threads we can
scroll to the worker threads section by
the way if you want to follow along the
link is included below say for example
that you want to download an image from
the network at this URL and then you
want to update the UI so that it
displays this bitmap well creating your
own thread to download the image is a
valid option but there's a lot of
overhead to handle in making your app
actually thread safe after you download
your image you cannot directly update
the UI from a background thread however
Android has several options to run code
that manipulates the UI from other
threads in this example yet another
runnable is created to get the bitmap
result back onto the main thread to
update the image view this solution is a
little cumbersome because you have to
manage to run herbals here to abstract
away this complexity we can use an async
task and then to kick off the async task
for example when someone clicks a button
then you just initialize the task and
then you can call execute on it and then
pass in any parameters that are needed
notice that when you're extending the
async class there's a couple of generics
that you need to specify the first is
the type that will be passed into the do
and background method so if you want to
pass in this image URL then you specify
string here and then in doing background
you'll get a string parameter the second
one is for the type of object that
you'll get when you get progress updates
as a task gets executed we're not using
that here so it's okay to specify that
as void and the third type is type of
results that we'll be sending back to
the main thread through the
onpostexecute method